we have this from CNN U.S lawmakers
introduced Bill to ban Tick Tock they
say Senator Marco Rubio the top
Republican the Senate intelligence
committee and a bipartisan pair of
congressmen in the house reflects the
latest escalation by U.S policy makers
against the Chinese owned short form
video app Tick Tock has faced doubts
about its ability to safeguard U.S user
data from the Chinese government I'm
pretty sure it just sends your data to
the Chinese government doesn't it yeah
yes absolutely and I mean do you think
it should be banned I do think it should
be banned and you've seen this with
Huawei huawei's made entrance into a lot
of developed countries it's been proven
time and time again that they are spying
on them they're collecting data this is
exactly what Tick Tock is doing we need
to be very clear that China is our
greatest adversary in the world we do
know that right and I think we need to
be acting as such
what should we do about Tick Tock ban it
get rid of it
well essentially they're doing with the
DHS and NSA are doing here domestically
inside of the United States I I think
the the bigger answer would be to make
people aware that everything they do
online isn't private everything is being
collected there's an entire data centers
that the United States is financing
through your tax dollars that literally
creates uh you know personality traits
about who you are what you're going to
be doing
um and Zuckerberg knows when you poop
exactly and but that's the lowest level
of it but it's not just about that it's
about how Tick Tock is feeding all this
woke stuff so we're talking about what's
going on in schools Tick Tock is a huge
component of crushing the brains of
young people in this country yes exactly
look at you know Chinese Tick Tock
versus U.S Tick Tock right right I mean
it's it's incredibly different the type
of algorithm that's being pushed here in
the United States it's trying to be
culturally destructive it's trying to be
divisive
um I think it is a huge problem I do
tax the E thoughts yeah
that's the crazy thing too that we've
talked about with like uh Instagram
somebody was mentioning how they they
searched first for I can't remember what
they're talking about you search for
anything on Instagram and it's going to
be some kind of sexualized content with
women and like
rule 34. no but I I guess but like not
not creating porn but like
you will just search for you know action
sports or something and then they will
find a way to feed or I should say young
women are finding a way to make content
seem sexual because it gets them clicks
the algorithm is generating this then
you have only fans that's the direction
we're going all of these things are just
components and it all Fallen apart yes
yeah I mean absolutely it goes back to
that generational transmission too I
mean if we were transmitting values
Norms I mean generationally to
Millennials and everybody else now I
mean would they be doing those things
you know I I'm not exactly sure now I
mean we're like in a society of me me me
me and and that's kind of what drives
all of this
it's crazy man I'm reading some of these
stories there's like some woman accused
of murder and she's like she's gonna pay
her bail with only fans money and I'm
like that's just so crazy these stories
about women who are like millionaires
now they figured it out just getting
naked on the internet and there's money
waiting but it doesn't work for
everybody ladies secure your bag all
right that being said it is probably not
a good idea to have an only fans
think about think about where we end up
in 10 years a woman who is 26 is making
a bunch of money and only fans
not all of them uh some of them you know
average I think the average is actually
pretty low yeah like the average is bad
it's like right not even like 70 bucks I
think but that's because yeah but that's
be that's like most people can make
money but of the one who do what happens
in 10 years they're 36. I have really
really bad opinions about this and I'm
it's it's making me nervous well now you
got to tell everybody well because it's
it's a it's it's a young it's a Young
Person's game and there are so many
young ladies that are told that because
they're that mistake being young for
being pretty and then they're fighting
in this slew of young people right young
women where they're just young they're
not really particularly pretty it's you
know it's it's like they they get this
idea that oh because the Five Guys that
keep hitting on me over at the at the
bar keep hitting on me and won't go away
I must be hot then they get on only fans
and then next thing you know there's
only fan or only girls on only fans
posting their L's posting these comments
from these these horribly broken women
that you know thought oh I'm pretty and
I'm gonna get on the internet and I'm
gonna make a lot of money because guys
think I'm pretty and then the internet
treats them like like horrible horrible
horrible you know but but it's rough
it's not it's not okay the point I want
to make is you get a woman let's say
she's attractive in 26. 10 years ago now
she's 36. a lot of the guys have either
paired up or are no longer interested
because they want a 26 year old but
she's still probably doing well and
attractive woman in a 30 is going to do
all right 46. now what happens to a
woman who has no discernible skills
because she spent a couple decades doing
only fans now she's in her late 40s what
does she do does she open like an only
Fan's Network to to court young talent
and manage their accounts for them or
something don't need to it's all
automated through the system does only
well let's assuming only fans last that
long or something like this happens
these women will eventually get too old
to be able to do this and make money and
then what then they go to the state and
they say the it's the government's fault
they should pay me yeah and that's not
even without the AI and Anime stuff
that's coming our way oh it's going to
totally destroy Society in many
different ways but I I just looked it up
the average only fans Creator earns
about
180 to 150 a month according to the best
estimates out there like that is can you
imagine thinking that you're a pretty
young girl at 20 years old right not and
like the only experience you've had is
in town everyone has treated you like
you're the hottest girl around because
there's 30 girls that are young young
and pretty and you're the hottest of the
30 but puts you in like you know on the
internet and then you're competing with
like beautiful women from all over the
world and you get treated like crap
because you're not as pretty as the
prettiest and it just destroys your
[ __ ] your self-esteem it's it's just
I'm not saying that there aren't that
women shouldn't do it I'm not the guy
that's going to judge people that do
that like that's not what I'm saying but
it's not as easy as people think it's
like like I'm a musician and I'm in a
band and the chances of me actually
succeeding for as long as I have it is
no nobody is is as lucky as I am like it
never happens the fact that I've been
doing this for 20 years as a as a
professional musician that wasn't even
in the cards I didn't think I'm gonna
start a band and I'm going to be
successful I thought I'm gonna start a
band and play on the weekends and work a
day job for the rest of my life right
that's what I expected and thankfully it
didn't work out that way and I'm super
fortunate but like your average person
your average young girl that starts and
only fans account thinking that she's
gonna you know she's gonna get beat up
emotionally and it's gonna it's gonna
hurt and it's just and they can never
take it back yeah okay that content will
always be on the internet people will
take pictures on their phones with
another phone or something like that and
you can never take it back and it's
going to come up in job interviews for
the rest of your life I mean it's just
you know like you're saying I mean the
odds of becoming a millionaire at this I
mean are so minimal but secondarily I
mean do you want to be in your 50s and
60s and trying to cling to relevance and
trying to still live that lifestyle it's
just that's a sad Road you know I I
don't I don't want to sound like I'm
coming off judging anybody at all you
know because I understand that there are
problems later in life that come along
with it and stuff but it's a I really
think that the most of the damage
happens to young people because of the
because of the expectation and then we
reality hits them because by the time
you're 40 if you've been living that
life you know what's coming you know
it's like if you've been living that
life you're 36 you're you know you're
like yeah man clock is ticking and these
things ain't up here anymore they're
down here or whatever you know it's like
that it's not like you're high that
that's a secret you know well another
aspect is that the market has become so
competitive it's not so you know I I
think talking to to some of the women
out there they have this notion that oh
I could just post whatever picture and
I'll get millions of dollars it doesn't
work that way a lot of the the biggest
earners work extremely hard uh on their
content on messaging people they have PR
teams they have they have entire
marketing teams that that work with them
it's not just as as some people think
like because again on average 150 a
month there's that uh that that old
saying every woman has boobs yeah every
woman has boobs they give you that
warning you know but it's not true
actually I think the average amount of
boobs is is less than two the average
the average amount of Limbs is less than
two one point 1.89 boobs per per woman
it is because like you get any
individual who's had like an amputation
or a mastectomy and then brings the
whole average down but my point is like
Lucas said there's a lot of a lot of
women who think they're going to be
successful at this not realizing that
there's a hundred plus million American
women you know you're competing with all
of the ones willing to do it which is a
lot and so that's like massive Supply
with with like demand can only get as
high as there are dudes but Supply is is
and if you're coming in cold like you've
never done any kind of Social Media
stuff they don't realize that like
content is dry is the driver you have to
keep feeding that content machine so
that means you gotta post pictures every
day and you gotta interact with the fans
that are paying you and blah blah blah
it's like and it's not stop work yeah
it's like more than uh nine to five
I can't post on my Instagram page enough
to feel like I am getting the most out
of my Instagram page yeah I mean if it
sounds too good to be true it's because
it is yeah so I mean it's a lot of work
it's hard you know and it's just it
sounds like it's oh look this person
makes millions but yeah that person is
probably not just like waking up taking
a picture and then going about there
yeah I mean like in your business that's
being like Oh somebody sings and they
make money I'll start singing it's not
how it works that's what people think
that is how they think what you know the
song Money for Nothing yeah yeah that
ain't working that's the way you do it
the guitar on the MTV yeah that's a good
song wasn't it like the the band was uh
they're like a Best Buy or something
they overheard some guy say that or
something like that I mean that I
wouldn't surprise me I I don't know the
story but urban legend but like I heard
a story that they were they were at like
a furniture store and they overheard two
guys watching one of their music videos
are watching music and like watching MTV
or something and then they were like
that ain't working you know that that's
the job we should get and it's just like
like
yeah it's probably more work it's it's
it's it's substantially more work people
think that like YouTube for instance
they're like man I really want to do
that and I'm like yeah it's like endless
work Mark wrote it after overhearing a
delivery man in New York Department
Store complained about their jobs while
watching MTV he wrote the songs in the
store sitting in a kitchen display they
had set up there you go any of the
lyrics were things they actually said
that ain't working that's the way you
play the guitar on the MTV Money for
Nothing in the chicks for free for
nothing then chicks for free and then a
lot of these musicians end up doing
drugs becoming extremely depressed they
hate their lives and uh it's funny when
you hear about these big bands that
break up and I remember growing up you'd
hear about a band that broke up or
whatever and then people would be like
why would they break up they were
successful and it's like yeah and the
other ones that don't do a bunch of
heroin right it must not be all that
great All That Remains is had you know
we had we had one person pass away a
couple years back uh one guy I was an
alcoholic or Eminem talk I don't drink
anymore uh you know so that kind of
light like the the lifestyle is real
we've gone through more drummers
probably gone through as many drummers
as uh as spinal tap I think like seven
or eight we go through drummers like mad
uh it's hard to play blast beats and
double bass man that's hard wait until
you find out about child celebrities oh
man and the people that Disney brings up
oh God I don't want to I don't want him
it's crazy man I I talked to uh Eliza
blue like she's on Twitter and stuff for
mutuals and stuff and hearing that poor
woman like she is so damn strong and the
work that she has done is really really
really great and hearing the the you
know the stories that she's she's
related it's I don't I don't I don't
envy that poor poor soul she is uh she's
done great work but man she is she has
paid you know thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time